ماذا يحدث للجسم عند الاضراب عن الطعام
سؤال اصبح متداولا بعد وفاه الاسير خضر
عدنان بالطبع نتائج هذا الامر تختلف من
جسم لاخر لكن الاحساس بالجوع يختفي في
اليوم الثالث تقريبا وفي الاسبوع الثالث
يبدا المضرب بالشعور بهاوسه كما يفقد
الشعور بالعطش وفي الاسبوع الرابع تدمر
خلايا العضلات نتيجه لاستهلاك البروتين
بعد الانتهاء من مخزون الدهون كما تصاب
العظام بالضعف ويفقد حينها المضرب نحو 25%
من وزنه وفي الاسبوع الخامس تزداد
احتماليه حدوث ضرر دائم في الدماغ واعضاء
الجسم الاخرى نتيجه لانعدام الجلوكوز وهنا
قد يفقد المضرب حاسه السمع والبصر وبعد
الاسبوع السادس تصبح امكانيه الوفاه عاليه
جدا مع احتمال فشل مفاجئ في القلب او
انسداد الشرايين